the 44 year old knows how to make a
statement number one slip back into your
ivory wedding gown number two smolder
with your husband for British Vogue
October cover and number three blast
those divorce rumors she calls them
nonsense and quote people have been
making things up about a relationship
for twenty years what is that thing that
keeps you guys together he's my soul
mate and we really support each other
but you have to make time for each other
you know we're busy so we make it work
as a family decked out in Dior the style
mogul / for kids and Cocker Spaniel
olive post sweetly for the magazine and
also wage war with squirt guns
David clearly lost we love that his
family doesn't take themselves too
seriously
case in point Victoria is marking 10
years of her fashion label with this
hilarious photo shoot spoof if there are
90s like Spice Girl era look that you're
okay with still I mean look I'm not
gonna do it again put it that way oh
never say never but proudly slipped back
into that cat suit 22 years later as
well as that LBD and that silver bustier
Minnie and gave us all kinds of spicy
flashbacks what I really really want to
spice up your life this really is where
to become one
I'm not quite as funky as I look I mean
I've said that for many years you know
I'm very very lucky to have the job that
I have you know the family that I have I
feel very very blessed
well you certainly can't call it frumpy
after sink that's hilarious though move
for herself right and she is left with a
beautiful family
[Applause]
[Music]